good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is stop making excuses
over to you Michael Jordan maybe it's
mindful
maybe I led you to believe it was easy
when it wasn't maybe I made you think my
highlight started at the free-throw line
and not in the gym maybe I made you
think that every shot I took was a
game-winner
[Music]
if my game was built on flash and not
fired
maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
that failure gave me strength that my
pain was my motivation
maybe I led you to believe that
basketball was a guy given gift and not
something I worked for
every single day of my life
maybe I destroyed the game
oh maybe you just makin excuses one of
the most common things that you'll find
for any of the people who are Michael
Jordan level talent at their field right
whatever whatever they are good at
whatever they are the best in the world
at they have Michael Jordan level
success at whatever they're doing they
don't complain they don't make excuses
it's consistent way if you look at the
people who are complaining and whining
the most they're a lot less successful
because it's easy just to blame somebody
else right you're not successful because
of the president or because of the
economy or because of your parents or
because your education or because of
whatever right as long as there's a
reason to blame then it's not your fault
and then you have to make any changes
it's not it's not your fault that you're
not more successful right it's it's the
government's fault so that means you are
a success you just have these
circumstances and so you can't do
anything and so you won't do anything
where the real change happens when you
realize you are accountable for your
life you may have been dealt a certain
hand you play that hand you can win with
that hand if you work hard if you hustle
there's never been more opportunities
than what we have existing today it's
never been easier to win if you're
willing to be passionate about something
and work hard and commit to it than at
any point in human history and so the
big change will happen for you when you
accept responsibility for where you are
in life one of the things that I find
easiest to remember and to relate to is
understanding that they're people who
have done way more than you those people
don't way more than me who came from way
worse than what I already have right now
people who have done way more than me
the new who started off with way less so
they could do it why can't I why can't
you and then the small thinking the
little man's can be all world they were
lucky they were lucky they were lucky
they had lucky breaks they had this luck
they had this luck as long as you
prescribe things to lock as long as you
are making excuses and blaming other
people you will never get to where you
want to go it just will not happen
get rid of luck get rid of your
complaints and excuses take
responsibility for your life and start
taking action and when you embrace that
that's when magical things start
to happen you deserve everything that
you have right now if I look at my
youtube channel I could say I can't
believe PewDiePie is number one I can't
believe the the logan paul's of the
world come on the youtubes and instantly
have millions of subscribers and i'm
here grinding out to get to my first
million by the end of the year right
it's easy to complain and look at the
people ahead of me and say listen I'm
making better content I'm trying to
inspire people with a positive message a
lot of the people ahead of me might be
having super negative content or just
trying to create drama and controversy
and negativity and that sucks that's not
fair that's unfair it's unfair that
these guys are having success and I'm
not as successful if I adopted that
mindset I would lose I would be worse
off than what I'm where I'm at right now
I deserve everything that I have I'm
grateful and super appreciative for the
eight hundred thousand plus subscribers
that we do have on the channel right now
and I deserve those and I've worked hard
for those and my team has worked hard
for that but I also don't deserve to be
at 8 million or 10 million or 15 million
or whatever they're at it's not good
enough is not providing enough value and
so we need to get better at it and
that's my fault I need to do better I
need to create better content for you I
need to be right on camera I need to
bring my team up and inspire them more I
need to have better clips I need to do a
better job all around it's not my team's
fault right it's not PewDiePie's fault
it's my fault
and so I deserve everything I have and I
don't deserve to have anymore
until I work harder to get there until
provide more value to get there and
you'll find that that's what successful
people do they accept accountability and
responsibility for where they are in
life they stop blaming their lack of
success on their lack of resources they
understand them that's never about the
resources you have it's the
resourcefulness that you had to go off
and create amazing things and if you
look at any self-made person look at the
people who had the most success the most
successful people in the world who built
massive fortunes who had a huge impact
they're not usually the children of
successful people
almost never they started from nothing
less than what you have right now and if
they were able to do it they were going
to take accountability for their life
they were able to stop complaining stop
blaming luck and turn something amazing
out of it then you came to so the
question today today is I'm curious what
has been the biggest excuse that you've
been making that maybe stops today
that's been holding you back the biggest
single excuse that you have believed
that is now holding you back and you're
gonna shed I'd love to hear from you
share it in the comments below I think
it also could inspire the other members
of believe nation watching in reading as
well I also want to give a quick shout
out to Jaron brown Jaron thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
vinspresso
we know that too many young men in our
community continue to make bad choices
and I have to say growing up I made
quite a few myself
sometimes I wrote off my own failings as
just as another example of the world
trying to keep a black man down I had a
tendency sometimes to make excuses for
me not doing the right thing but one of
the things that all of you have learned
over the last four years is there's no
longer any room for excuses I understand
there's a common fraternity Creed here
at Morehouse excuses are tools of being
competent used to build bridges to
nowhere and monuments of nothingness
well we've got no time for excuses not
because the bitter legacy of slavery and
segregation have banished entirely they
have not not because racism and
discrimination no longer exists we know
those are still out there
it's just that in today's
hyper-connected hyper-competitive world
with millions of young people from China
and India and Brazil many of whom
started with a whole lot less than all
of you did all of them entering the
global workforce alongside you nobody is
going to give you anything that you have
not earned nobody cares how tough your
upbringing was nobody cares if you
suffered some discrimination
and moreover you have to remember that
whatever you've gone through it pales in
comparison to the hardships previous
generations endured and they overcame
them and if they overcame them you can
overcome up to I decided to go to film
school because I loved the idea of
making films on a photography and
everybody said it was a crazy thing to
do because in those days nobody made it
into the film business I mean just
unless you were related to somebody
there was no way in so everything I was
silly you're never gonna get a job but I
I wasn't moved by that I set the goal of
getting through film school and just
then focused on getting to that level
because I didn't you know I didn't know
where was gonna go after that I wanted
to make documentary films and eventually
I got into the goal of once I got to
school of making a film one of the most
telling things about film schools you
got a lot of students in those days
especially it's not quite so much today
but wandering around say oh I wish I
could make a movie I wish I could make a
movie you know I can't get in this class
I can't get any you know first class I
have was an animation class it wasn't a
production class I had a history class
and an animation class and in the
animation class they gave us one minute
of film to put onto the animation camera
to operate it to see how you could move
left move right make it go up and down
and it was a test to see you know then
the teacher would you had certain
requirements that you had to do you had
to make you go up mad at me go down and
then the teacher would look at it and
say oh yes you maneuvered this machine
to do these things and I took that one
minute of film and made it into a movie
and it was a movie that won like
you know 20 or 25 Awards you know in
every film festival in the world and
kind of changed the whole animation
department and there and and meanwhile
all the other guys were and said well I
wish I could make a movie which is a
production class and so then I got into
another class and it wasn't really a
production class but I managed to get
some film when I made a movie and I made
lots of movies while I'm in school while
everybody else was running around
saying oh I wish I could make it move it
we're having this conversation about
when he plays in sports or when he does
something about you go full-out or do
you not and I see sometimes in him that
when he's out on the field of doing
something he doesn't play full out and
I'll have an excuse like my leg hurts or
my arm hurts or something happened the
coach was unfair what other hanger the
referee was unfair and what happens with
people is we tend to go out into the
world and we look for those sort of
excuses about why things aren't the way
we want them and when you do that you
lose all your power in life when you
start focusing on the external on the
excuses you lose your power here is the
way people really think I will tell you
I can go out on the stage and bomb you
go out there you just bomb right and
people will respect you for going out
there and trying your hardest it's not
how you actually perform that earns you
the respect of your peers it's the fact
that you went out and actually did it
that's the difference